good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy tuesday hope
everyone's having an
amazing day amazing so far
no good you guys the un is my personal
kryptonite
and
it's just it's
it's only i can't believe it's just the
beginning of the week okay but here's a
good sign this is me my new positivity
uh i see you've cracked out your
official boots with for winter i did and
that's the sign that we are truly
falling into fall that's true and also
um i was kind of regretting it because i
had to walk um this morning because just
like traffic is really crazy in new york
so don't come here this week if you were
thinking about it and they were like too
heavy for the walking you have to think
about these things when you're pregnant
because everything tires you out jerry
you have to think about those things
when you're pregnant and when you're fat
you have no idea like we are so
simpatico right now i think about
everything before i leave the house and
i actually cracked out yesterday my like
sarah knock off of your boots and this
is what happens when you buy sarah i
love these boots i really wore them like
to the bone last winter and there's no
more it's like i couldn't get a new pair
i got home yesterday and like the boot
fell off the sole like it's just split
right down the middle don't worry i'm
literally taking them to the shoe maker
having to spend more than what i
actually spent on the cheap ass boots
why don't you just get whatever the
designer version is of them because you
clearly love them and then they'll last
you many years well because i have to
say i love this hour once i really have
no complaints other than like the
terrible quality because they're so
comfortable and last year i remember i
spent the whole day like ready to spend
the money on like the real boots that i
was knocking off i couldn't even find
them and everywhere i went they were
giving me like stumpy little like yeah
cankles yeah it was cankle season so i
found boots that i like and i'm gonna
spend every dollar i have to maintain
their integrity okay that's you know
everyone has their own journey speaking
of maintaining integrity this is a
downton abbey spoiler and it's a really
big one so i'm giving you ten seconds
okay ten
nine
eight
[Music]
okay last night i finished season three
and to be quite honest
i'm shocked
spoiler alert
matthew dies
which is
so unnecessary like i can't even begin
to explain because with sybil it was
like the perfect death like nobody
actually cared but like it was a big
deal for the family and it was like
shocking but like it didn't affect the
integrity of the show
from here on out yeah now i only watched
like 10 minutes of the next episode
because i was so like i was so defeated
like i just i mean
and you know they had to do it in the
most painful way like they had the baby
it's an air they're so happy he's
driving home the sun's in his eyes he's
laughing he's smiling he
dead splat concrete splat
and
to be honest i'm not really interested
in watching a show without matthew
and i don't know how that's going to
affect the rest of the seasons i
understand i mean sitting here and
listening to you going through downton
abbey it's been hard for me to know
what's coming for you
and even still like there's so much
coming good and bad
and it's just a journey
but it's okay it's so you know what it
turns out to be okay no here's the other
thing here's the other thing
with sybil it was like all right she
wasn't even like a character like i
really liked but with matthew he was
like i feel like as a show goes on
everyone's getting worse and worse i
used to love the dad robert he's
actually the worst character on the show
he's so
stubborn and just like he's the worst
and mary now that she's in mourning is
like a [ __ ] to everyone and she gets
really [ __ ] sometimes and now she's
like in a permanent permanent state of
bitchiness edith is pathetic the mom is
sweet and all we have is the dowager
because matthew's mom for like the last
two seasons has really started to piss
me off with her self-righteousness yeah
so now i feel like i'm left with
literally like just the dowager with the
characters who i stand no but then you
still have like carson and everyone
downstairs true but still the family is
sort of disintegrating
just
give it a b you know down to never stays
down for long stays down for long it's
true and by the way those three words
that i was thinking of for people who
have watched downton claudia finally
closed the chapter on thomas's um
scandal and whether or not he was going
to be fired or not the three little
words were her
soap which was sent to chill down my
spine right i never forgot it i never
forgot it either because honestly i
thought that was a secret that was going
to die with me so brian oh and miss
o'brien just literally bounced
for um
their cousin who like wants to move to
bombay and do her hair with o'brien
right so that's good news at least yeah
but like she was bothering me less and
less and you know the woman who comes in
to replace o'brien is a really good
casting like she adds a lot of value
well i'm just like i i need a minute
like before i just dive back in because
i was like riding such a high last night
like the baby and i was like yeah
oh my god and lily james was a real
surprise i haven't seen any actress did
i bring this up yesterday no no i
haven't seen any actress on downton
abbey that i really um have recognized
from anywhere else like i couldn't even
play stan stevens so to see someone you
know like dominic west's lover
rolling into downton it was very jarring
and i didn't like it and i also just
don't like her character
agreed she will stop bothering you so
much it was definitely jarring the first
time i saw her too but now she's just
like a part of the she's a fabric
yeah and her characters like has so much
energy and it's like yes like relax yeah
relax but what's also crazy which you
didn't care about when i first told you
but in the downtown in the next downton
movie downton sequel
dominic west is in it
what yeah i saw that on the bill i think
it's just out here ruining things that i
don't know like what his role would be
ugh
hopefully he's like a pa you know yeah
yeah well that's my downton journey i
will keep you abreast on all things
downton but just know i'm currently
grieving
um
and i'm just gonna have to figure a way
out of this but
i have no choice and we have a great
show for you guys today because it's
tuesday so we're doing deer toasters
and we also yesterday recorded a
fabulous interview finally with aaron
gilfoy and carly and contro from the
vlog squad from their podcast you guys
follow them on youtube you know them um
i sat down with them and we did a great
little interview that'll be at the end
of this podcast episode and if you're
watching on youtube we also filmed it so
it'll just be um on our channel a
separate video with the three of us
so fun so fun like such girly girls
toasters so you know it's really nice to
talk to people
with similar interests you know 100
and they're so interesting you know like
they got started on vine
like that's how they launched their
careers oh that's so cool yeah i can't
wait to watch yeah it was really good um
i am trepidatiously watching outlander
because you guys have really scared me
because so many people have messaged me
stop they say stop right now do not
watch trauma everywhere you go and i've
narrowed it down to one specific episode
and i've tried to get a sense of what it
could be that's so
so terrible and i've also heard like
someone said like don't watch it this
scene because like you're pregnant and
like apparently it's just really you
know traumatizing are you easily
traumatized i'm not
it just depends some things like really
like i think some things that would
bother other people
wouldn't bother me but then sometimes
things live in my mind run through for
the rest of time that is such a good
call like but and you know what i think
this is compared to not in the act
itself but the way that it lives red
freeing your mind like when you think
about it you just your day is ruined the
pig the pig yeah i have a few things
that live red for it in my mind the pig
is obviously one of them
the trundle yeah then there's like some
episodes of svu like comparatively
because svu airs on cable it can never
be that crazy but there's that episode i
brought it up before where liv goes
undercover because there is a guard
who's abusing the women and you know the
undercover op gets like [ __ ] and she
ends up like locked in a basement with
this man
and
that's like pretty tame compared to what
we see on streaming services like but
it's still like if i ever think about it
i can't go to sleep
everyone has their things right so i
think my plan is i'm gonna everyone said
it's the last episode of season one so
i'm gonna watch up until that
if i'm really enjoying the show still
i'll just skip the episode launch into
season two and then someone could maybe
brief me on what i missed i just can't
even fathom what it could be that has
everyone being like do not watch the
show yeah like now i'm kind of curious
like right you want me to go watch it
because i don't watch the show i don't
watch the show okay or you guys just dm
claudia and tell her what it is
okay fine right yeah
or like i'll just go watch it okay vlog
it for the patreon
so but it's been fun i mean
if i can't if i have to stop watching
the show because of it though
i wouldn't be that upset it's not like
obsessed
no but it's it's nice and it's a good
hearty show i just don't know where it's
going like does she ever get back into
time to frank it's no doubt or does
frank come to her like
it's no doubt in him but
nothing can be downton nothing
um so yeah we have a great show it's
gonna be nice and long and i feel like
we should just dive in you think we
should dive in yeah i mean i have
literally nothing else to share i spent
the whole day like waiting for ben to be
done working so we could watch downton
and honestly today i'm not gonna be as
generous like because you know what i
waited for him all night he got home so
late from a meeting eight o'clock and we
start watching and he's like on his
phone so it's like you may evaluate as
much as i do and i waited all day no
more yeah no more so [ __ ]
disrespectful do you want to talk about
the vest in the room because you're just
like sitting here looking so cool yes
i'm wearing a vest you guys because it's
officially in the 60s it hasn't been in
the 60s yet so i've been waiting to take
out my 818 vest that unfortunately i did
not get for free and i did pay for but
um it's still cool it's just watercolor
slice it i love a vest like it's really
cool look at me so free because it's a
vest no it really is the best season and
it's such a cool vest so
yeah i got it for freight
super cool thank you thanks for pointing
it out so i could talk about it
you're welcome
and my look it's all from asos maternity
today so i'm just feeling super
comfortable by the way when i hear just
how sympathetic though we are sure i
placed like a i have so many like
engagement parties bridal showers
weddings and like i just need dresses
and honestly everything at revolve is on
pre-order especially if you're looking
for a size extra large like best of luck
maybe you could try sears like but so i
went on other places and i haven't
chopped down asos in a while and i got a
bunch of dresses and it was like this
really cute dress for a wedding and it
was maternity i'm like i got a big belly
so you got it for sure okay great i'll
borrow it yeah and i'll see if it fits
great yeah i can't wait to show me what
it is i need dresses too asos mater asos
in general is just like catering to all
of us the petite the tall the curve the
maternity and i just want to say asos we
see you for seeing us and we are
grateful it's really true because all
ladies are not built the same all
pregnant ladies are not built the same
and asos sees us
and when i'm shopping maternity clothes
i just go by my size like of not
maternity like i'm a small
so people were asking me like what size
do you get maternity clothes like small
because they're taking care of them the
maternity the belly yeah right right
um okay now without further ado
where are you right here being so
beautiful
stunning and smart it is time for the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
oh my god oh my god i'm sorry my rgh
just like
attacked me
i'm trying to be creative and inventive
could you at least like be supportive i
just want you to know if i did that like
scared you you would have had to take
like three minutes off of the show of
course because i know you don't scare
easily like and i do so that would be
rude of you but it's fine for if i do it
okay cool and i'm sorry that i just got
so scared because the looming sense of
rdh was like so spooky okay well why
don't you get it off your chest let us
know what you need us to know thank you
for indulging me today's episode is
brought to you by all birds you guys are
going to be so excited to try the all
birds tree dashers it's time to get
outside more and honestly if you're not
getting outside with all birds like just
stay inside the all birds tree dasher is
a truly sustainable running shoe built
for performance with low environmental
impact so you can run hard and tread
light on the planet the tree dasher is a
carbon neutral
thanks to sustainable practices like
using natural materials and
buying carbon offsets they run you can
run confidently knowing that all birds
are locked with thousands of miles with
50 plus amateur and pro athletes over a
year-long test period they're the most
comfortable they're so stylish they come
they come in ton of colors and they're
so comfortable it's what we were just
saying like now it's the best time
weather-wise and like you should be
walking everywhere but you were like
stomping around in your big boots it's
just not gonna work like put on the all
birds go for a jog if you're me just
like go for a walk they're so cool and
like everyone wears them like
celebrities are obsessed with them so
like you'll look famous if you wear them
this fall put your best foot forward
with the all birds tree dasher discover
your perfect pair of all birds dot at
all birds today at allbirds.com that's
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s
dot com again discover your perfect pair
at
allbirds.com a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s
dot-com
great love alberts yeah
okay first story little real estate news
kanye has reportedly bought a 57.3
million dollar malibu escape amid his
divorce and i just have to say
this is
true
thievery i opened this tmz article 57
million dollars on a malibu beach house
when i think that i think something you
know double triple the size of yolanda's
home in malibu right it's literally
a townhouse on the ocean i was shocked
it's like one of those houses where it's
like the houses are all next to each
other you know when you drive on pacific
coast and they're beautiful and they
look out but literally 57 million
dollars to be living on top of your
neighbors no i know the townhouse that's
that's beach front in in california and
that's robbery it's highway ride i agree
and i actually am shocked that kanye
would be into this
home i mean obviously the style of home
everyone's making fun of it's very like
concrete they're saying parking garage
no and like that with those homes in
malibu like the front of the home faces
the ocean so the only thing you see is
the back you see like the garage and
literally you pull up to it i swear it
looks like a one-story home like
it could be anywhere like it could be
yeah in long island it could be in
queens like it's there's literally
nothing unique about it well i'm like
the interior school and it's very modern
and clearly he wants a little beach
access and he's willing to pay 57
million dollars for it i can't get over
that like this is robbery and next
question are the beaches that it's on
public beach no
i have no idea but i can't imagine okay
but just like okay so that's like one
home it's literally a townhome
surrounded by like 15 others all of them
are like 50 60 million dollar homes
right it's the dumbest thing i've ever
heard in my entire life i know and it
just really seems like not kanye he
seems like personal space like you know
in wyoming wyoming and even their house
in
calabasas or wherever it is is like
expansive and there's no one around they
have so much property it's like he's
living in manhattan in a walk up yeah
it's oh and 57 million dollars like i
cannot get over it yeah if i have 57
million dollars
i'm taking it to
i'm splitting it up i'm getting a farm
like i'm getting
10 million here 10 million five hundred
times like a penthouse penthouses are
actually very secluded like you get your
space like i'm i'm not doing this that's
what i'm saying like literally this is
the opposite of what i'm doing i agree i
would i would split it up
for sure because honestly no beach house
really even like you can get the nicest
possible beach house for like 11 million
dollars you don't need to spend clearly
not no and also like
i've only been to one beach in malibu
and this is a hot take i didn't think it
was that great the beach itself yeah
like the sand like the sand and the
atmosphere and just like the vibe i was
like
i don't know i i'm gonna disagree with
you i don't think there's any better
vibe on earth than like nobu malibu i'm
just saying the actual beach like the
sand the ocean
like this is everything no it's gorgeous
i'm saying texture-wise the beach yeah
okay
like if i had 57 million to stand on a
beach house my beach house is going to
be an island off the coast of turks and
caicos like
this is nuts
no one else agreeing with me like it's
nuts no this i think everybody agrees
with you plus they don't like the style
of the house which it's not okay by the
way if it was like this
unique style of even like rage parcel
designed it no no but like even if it
was like this really a design that i
thought was heinous
let's say i do think farmhouse is
heinous but he will do modern farmhouse
hate what's to hate oh my god it's so
overdone like the tufted couches like i
just i i
hate so like jerry's house you don't
like
that's not modern farmhouse oh by the
way that's like the or the outside is
modern farmhouse i'm talking about
inside decor like
like
hold on give me a second okay show me
some pictures yeah that's such a hot
take
farming house interior design here like
yeah like let me see it's so
it's so like basic
it's nice to i mean it's pleasant no
it's pleasant not for me okay but uh
interior the out the inside of derby's
house is actually like very contemporary
but the outside is like farmhouse vibes
modern farmhouse yeah but like these
types of like
lighting units like i don't like
farmhouse interior modern farmhouse okay
um
but wait back no so what i was saying
was like okay even if i don't like the
interior but it's like a palace i'm like
i can respect that it's not my style but
it's a palace this is literally like a
garage
that's also ugly
yeah if you know what i'm saying it's
very harsh
that it is that's very kanye but it's
also not i'm so confused no but you know
chrissy teigen and john
what's his face
had a
beach house that they were always
posting at and i do believe they
recently sold it and it was sickening
like a malibu b chess it was like so
many stories it was gorgeous like and i
think it was like 20 million so like i
just feel like honey got a bad deal
i'm telling you maybe it's like on a
different stretch of beach like maybe
this is prime location i don't know i
don't know it just doesn't seem like a
good investment and i know nothing about
money i agree but kanye knows a lot so
i'm just gonna trust him on this one or
maybe he has a plan maybe he's gonna buy
up the block
oh that makes sense like literally one
billion dollars later yeah literally
okay our next story you guys a little
update from yesterday i know everybody's
been like
shaking in their boots waiting with
baited breath but christina hack has
confirmed her engagement to joshua hall
and tarek has already congratulated her
is it a people exclusive so
she announced her engagement on
instagram tarek went to people to tell
them that they just saw congratulations
targ is so thirsty and a lot of [ __ ] on
the internet realized that christina's
ring was made by the same jeweler that
tariq had heather's made from
none of this surprises me whatsoever no
it's the most incestual i'm just waiting
to hear what um renee zellweger thinks
about christina's engagement like i
don't think she cares honestly that
we're also wrapped up in this circle but
like renee zellweger is like so a-list
so like cut off from reality i'm sure
she doesn't even know like who ann said
yesterday she has no idea who these
people are oh but you know and they have
kids together right aunt and christina
do they i do believe they have one child
oh
yeah
can you
if they do then renee is going to be
forced to be in christina's life which
is insane
but if they don't it's a clean break but
i'm pretty sure they have a child okay
i'm just going to go to the last time
she was pregnant
which was in 2021 yeah
this is so crazy like this group of
people just moves incredibly fast
there's so much toxicity there's so much
incest there's so much weirdness like
the fact that heather ray young used to
host a podcast with christina hack's
fiance's sister like so much weirdness
it's like there's 11 people in orange
county and they're all like just getting
married and remarried and engaged and
having babies and
tarik and christine are at the center of
it and so is their atrocious hgtv show
like you want to talk about something
with people with no style you have to
watch one [ __ ] episode of their show
they do the same thing in every home and
it's white subway tile marble quartz
counters like it's so basic they re do
oh like every fireplace with just like
white subway tile
white brick white everything you know
linen floors it's so basic
tarek does like the layout and christina
does the style and honestly i don't know
who has like less taste
interesting i'm going to say i never
watched an episode honestly it's so
boring literally they go to like a
[ __ ] house that's like been you know
foreclosed or like hoarders it's
disgusting they flip it or they flop it
yeah and like they never really flop it
because like sometimes what they
consider a flop like it just hasn't sold
yet like but it's done
and it will sell and like the episode
just ended you know then christina has
her own show now like christina by the
ocean yeah christina takes the beach or
whatever because they're so toxic
together they can't even be in the same
room
um but i really would love for you to
watch one episode of flip-flop like it's
it's torture like it's this and you know
once you've seen one you've seen them
all they walk into a dirty home
christina's like
oh tarek's like oh did i watch one from
when they were married or not married
literally the same like it doesn't
matter but watch when they were married
just so you could really see like the
underlying issues um and then like tarik
demos it kristina takes the kid goes to
the marble store and it's like should we
do this one or this one i like this one
but it's more expensive but like what
will daddy say she obviously goes with
the more expensive one she comes back
tarik is like oh my god we're so over
budget and he tries to find like other
ways to like cheap out and you know like
justice for whoever you know buys the
house because tara cut like one thousand
corners then their
you know contractor comes in is like
we found a pipe you know it's always
like something like
termites
molds something and they have to counter
that into the budget then they have this
fake open house where like actual paid
actors come to be like oh what a great
master bedroom is that a wood-burning
fireplace and then at the end they like
pretend someone buys it once you
honestly i just did such a great i feel
like i was there every episode is the
exact same nothing unique ever happens
ever okay
okay but it's so good
is it no it's a churches especially like
when you're watching reruns on
hgtv and you just happen to catch like a
fabulous old episode of fixer-upper and
you see the love between chip and joe
and the home style even though it's not
always my style it's so unique and so
thoughtful like every corner of the home
is built with love for the family and
literally like then you go to target
christina who can't stop fighting and
literally the home is just a factory
like there's no thought nothing it's
just like literal like model homes
i'm dying okay thank you for that
i could literally give a ted talk like
on the intricacies of like being a
couple on hgtv and then there's that
couple from hometown have you ever
watched hometown no what's that they're
like a poor man's chip and joe but
they're so sweet and they care so much
about their neighborhood that's why
they're like successful similar to chip
and joe i think they live in like some
random town in minneapolis but they
preserve the old homes in their
neighborhood and
it's just like everything in in the
house comes you know like oh this would
burn this you know this wood table like
you know the pilgrims ate here like
there's always something like and then
she like does a watercolor of the house
and frames it for the people like it's
so cute that's cute sounds like it has a
historical touch to it by the way like
it's literally historical fiction like
you have to watch it okay okay thank you
you've given me a lot of homework
yeah i mean you've watched fixer-upper
before right yes and also i like their
stuff on magnolia i watch gotta get on
the magnolia chat her cooking show no
home shows don't really do it for me
really yeah i don't watch any hgtv but
um
like i like her cooking show on magnolia
network i watched all the episodes that
were out
when like i was watching them i went
through a phase where i watched
every single fixer-upper it was all on
netflix like one summer i just watched
every single one and i'm obsessed and
then like i just hgtv really was born
out of necessity for me
because me and ben went on a vacation in
aruba and the tv was like not working
and there was nothing on except hgtv and
i never watched it before chip and joe
were on and my life was forever changed
it's beautiful yeah
are you ready for our next story sure
dancing with the star season 30
premiered last night and they finally
revealed which pros the celebs are
paired with and i know you guys were on
the edge of your seats wondering who's
going to be paired with who don't be
condescending like some people were like
no by the way people who are obsessed
with dancing with the stars like go on
the tour and are obsessed not even with
the stars but with the pros like they
couldn't wait like this was like a huge
this is like finding out who the next
bachelor is for people okay i'm dead
serious like what does it mean like
there are just some fan favorites like
valkyrie murkowski and there's also like
some people who are always like thrown
into like okay
are they dating and then there's also
people who just take one for the team
every single time like i feel like
cheryl is that her name
uh we'll go through okay but jojo siwa
made history with the same sex dancing
partner jenna johnson churkovsky
very cute very cute very exciting amanda
clutes and alan burstin
oh alan burstin was the one who danced
with hannah and won
okay um i found him on i only watched it
seems like he keeps getting the
professional answers i found him to be
so annoying like and i felt like hannah
found him to be so annoying too he's
just like always like glomming onto her
like and just like but i feel like they
also had to like pretend like are they
aren't they yeah it's good for ratings i
don't i actually don't particularly like
him like he just has a face i don't like
nothing against him just just his face
suny lee and sasha farber i don't know
if that is
mel c and gleb savchenko who you dated
listen to rum
he dated her that's like there was a
rumor that she dated lisa vanderpump but
also there was a rumor that he actually
was one of erica jane's mistresses
because mr misters he was erica's
partner that i remember about him
melora hardin and artem nikki's husband
okay i heard melora harden like killed
it i watched a few of the performances
yeah we want to get your thoughts when
it's just one of those shows like it's
an abc thing like they have to waste as
much of your time especially in the
first episode like they're gonna let you
everyone they're gonna let you know what
these stars have been up to since the
day they were born it's so annoying like
it's just one of those shows that has no
respect from your time and whoever is
ahead of time management at abc like
fired
kenya moore and brandon armstrong i
don't know who brandon is me neither
christine chu and pasha poshkov
no brian austin green and sharna burgess
oh that's cute oh i didn't put this
together that this would be happening oh
i'm gonna watch your performance because
i would like to see the chemistry um
that's actually really okay that makes
him being on the show
more she's cuter this is cute if they
were to win like which they won't they
won't but i don't i didn't watch so who
am i to say maybe he's super talented um
okay
something not losery from brian awesome
green shocking cody rigsby and sheryl
burke
oh she did not take one for the team
that's what i was saying cheryl is by
the way so i'll be a winning duo i
actually think i've done a lot of
thinking about this and i think that the
top two
are going to be cody rigsby and jojo
siwa that's just my thought
you think okay because they're both
really good dancers and have
huge platforms okay and they're not
riddled by scandal at all like they are
perfect like brand safe people okay i'm
gonna go with your list and then i'll
give you my prediction
matt james and lindsey arnold okay so i
watched their performance and i have to
say matt james was
excellent there are so many guys
especially really tall guys like former
athletes who have no rhythm like it's so
painful to watch and it's just a matter
of days before they get sent home matt
was excellent i have to say it's so much
easier for a boy to be good because in
like these women carry the damn these
traditional dances like the man just
like stands there and like twirls she
does the twirling right and so if your
partner's a girl it's actually much
easier to like
show her off no but he was very good
easier to make the dance look good but i
think it's harder to stand out yes
that's true
he was very good like i was super
surprised okay cool i feel like even if
he's really good i don't think we're
gonna have another bachelor winner me
neither and
they're
back to the power of bachelor nation is
not behind matt james because they like
hold him and rachel kirk connell
responsible for chris harrison and they
like justice for chris harrison and they
like don't like matt and rachel oh so i
don't think they're gonna i don't think
he's gonna make it very far for that
reason alone like most bachelor people
make it like
a couple weeks in just like even if
they're not that great they're all both
on abc the people who watch the bachelor
watch dancing with the stars it's like
you know the next channel the next night
but like the bachelor nation that like
got caitlyn and got hannah to win they
do i do i just think i do not think they
stand behind matches you don't think the
energy is there no okay the miz and
whitney carson she's one of my favorite
pros me too and was what's this
um like i just personally it's like one
of those things i cannot
you can no i can't okay i can't okay
well
you know and i won't hopefully for
whitney they do pretty good i love
whitney too
olivia jade and val chermkovsky so he's
like the most popular most famous most
followed so like this was a very um
good pairing for olivia jade and i did
watch her
and she was excellent like her footwork
was there she like looked a little
unsure of herself but it's the first
week i'm telling you in three weeks like
she's gonna be the best dancer like she
was so good i was shocked wow like and
she's like she was hesitant at times but
like she could do every single move so
like once she gets more comfortable like
being on tv
and
with her dancing like i'm telling you
she was really good oh that's exciting
yeah and she's making me like want to
watch but i can't sit down and watch
literally what you have to do is like
every tuesday morning before the toast
like just watch the performances on
youtube there's no need to watch the
other 55 no sorry an hour and 55 minutes
because
the packages the scoring everything is
so [ __ ] drawn out yeah and honestly i
have no respect for the people who give
scores because they're so inconsistent
and they choose favorites and there's no
real structure to the scores yeah okay
next we have jimmy allen and emma slater
that's cute is jimmy ellen single i
don't know that's a cute couple i wonder
out of everyone here like which
couple is comprised of two single people
you know valet kumarkovsky is not right
he's
yeah i don't think so but i think olivia
jade is single
uh i don't think so i think she is oh
you think i think like recently i don't
know where i know that from but i think
she is okay
um i don't know is melora harden married
because i kind of like i'm living for
this moment for well she's with artem
who's married to nikki right right yeah
so they have to be both single but i do
feel like dancing with the stars would
pair the two single people like who are
age-appropriate yeah together with ellen
um
let me go back to the sorry no no
because i do believe alan's singing
amanda cloots
oh that no she could do better okay um
yeah so
it's one of those shows like i'm very
interested in but like cannot watch but
i do watch on youtube yeah and like i
like knowing like what happened
sometimes like people share a personal
story that's like you know touching
touching so we'll see iman shumpert and
daniella kargak i don't know who that
danella she is
oh she looks familiar
then martin cove and brit stewart don't
know who either of those people are same
he'll be the first one to go home that's
the cast very exciting it's a really
good cast so i don't really like with
dancing with the stars i'm very like
anxious and excited to hear about the
people who get cast i don't really care
about the partners because i'm not
involved in like the dancing with the
stars universe but so many people are
and like it means the world to them like
who gets paired and they think it means
a lot but i'm putting my money out there
like cody rigsby and jojo siwa are
making it extremely fun i think one of
them's gonna win what about amanda klutz
i don't think
you don't think she has like the the
platform in the sense that like she's
really famous and she's on the talk and
like everyone knows who she is i don't
think she has like hordes of teenagers
you know waiting up all night and voting
10 times okay that's just my opinion but
i do think she'll make it far okay what
about you
i don't know whatever i guess is going
to be wrong
so would say cody rigsby i would agree
with that one yeah jojo what's her dance
good did you see it yeah she and she's
an abby lee dance girl like she's a good
dancer
right i feel like everyone here is a
good dancer everyone has some dancing
bags and there's also going to be have
to be someone who's like not
what you like not the typical like who's
like sort of like a uh an underdog it's
gonna be melora harden yeah which by the
way if she wins like i'm one thousand
percent here for that like we stand with
laura harden jacqueline from
the valentine the bowl type what's her
last name
jaclyn
i don't know carlisle
yeah that sounds right
i don't know
okay are you ready for our next story
which is a little game that a little
trivia not trivia like
well i'll just explain it people's
sexiest man alive is open for voting and
i it's about time i'm going to so we're
voting in all the like cringy categories
best feet there's 20 of them
let's go through as many as we can okay
because i want to know and we'll place
our votes
do they have nominees or we just
nominate they have nothing okay they
have nominees sorry oh this is fun yeah
who is the sexiest tv star we have paul
wellesley from vampire diaries oh that's
i think that's still on it's not and i
thought you were talking about paul
mezcal from normal people and he wins
right so why is he nominated is this
article from 2013 or is it fresh it was
fresh it was in the trending this
morning that's so weird okay okay jensen
ackles the boys
we uh i don't know
kikowa kikumanu from the white lotus
uh he played oh the jewel thief did you
worthy okay so far he has my vote me too
jared padalecki from walker and shaymar
moore from criminal minds
oh flip it around
i think i just want to make sure shmar
more 100 really jackie have you ever
seen criminal minds baby girl you know
like i'm airdropping you this link so
you can place your own books and i can
place my voice shamar more is so hot and
by the way have you ever seen him
watching i've seen criminals have you
ever seen him on watch out inside with
phaedra parks and like literally
shipping so hard it was the cutest
episode shabar bore and by the way he is
the voice behind that tic toc sound i'm
sorry i'm just in a silly goofy mood
that's really funny okay so you'll vote
more for who you want i voted for kiko
okay who are the sexiest song of the
summer silk sonic leave the door open
justin bieber peaches call me by your
name little nauseas bts butter and rao
alejandro todo de ti
um
it's gonna be justin bieber for me or
leave the door open okay so you could
vote for justin bieber and i'll vote for
silk sonic leave the door open yeah
because it's more about the song and not
the person right like which song did i
like better i liked peaches they said
who
oh no who who had the sexiest song not
which sexy person had a song it's about
the song and i'm going peaches okay i
can't i just can't vote for you i don't
even need to swipe through this next
sexiest summer olympian
caleb but also tom daley bobby fink noah
lyles and nigel hostin are nominated but
no
sexiest first time dad i'm crying colin
joe blasberg colin jost joshua jackson
henry golding
derek blasberg jason derulo okay i just
want to say i'm really happy for derek
blasberg for getting nominated and i
just know like this means a lot to him
you know yeah but you're voting for
colin jost obviously of course yeah
so hot i'm voting for jason derulo i was
thinking about also voting for joshua
jackson because i think he's so hot yeah
i agree but i stand by my decision i
stand by my decision too who's the
sexiest marvel hottie and we don't
really [ __ ] with marvel no so we'll have
to know them from something else daniel
kaluuya black panther tom holland
spiderman chris evans avengers good
thing they have pictures otherwise we
people which chris is witch yeah um
simulu shanxi and sebastian stan the
falcon and winter soldier hmm
i just feel like i don't want to vote
here like i don't really know i feel
like it's not fair for me to vote i
agree i agree
sexiest newlywed not justin hartley
derrick fisher blake shelton alexander
ludwig or gz it's gonna be like shelton
for me me too remember when he got
nominated and no he was sexiest man
alive and it was like the biggest
controversy in our country to date
literally here today like the biggest
were the days it was bigger than mexico
who is the sexiest newly single guy
simon baker tyler cameron blair
underwood a-rod bill gates okay i'm
sorry
bill gates like
they're trolling us people's got jokes
yeah like this is not okay simon baker
is also the man from devil wears prada
who
you think who i think is billy bush
right
so
it's between tyler cameron and blair
underwood it's obviously tyler cameron
because because he's a friend of the
toast because he's a friend of ours
theo's best friend and theo would
actually like literally knock me out if
i couldn't oh my god i am triggered by
the next one this next question who is
the sexiest real estate king drew scott
chip gaines tarek el moussa jonathan
scott jason oppenheim you guys chip
games chip games there's only one i'm
offended by every other only one choice
oh and this next one is the easiest
question i've ever had to answer sexiest
tv chef ludacris gordon ramsay guy fieri
eddie jackson anthony uh from queer eye
guy fieri he's so [ __ ] sexy he should
be on the cover who took the sexiest
vaccine selfie this is so stupid
everyone's wearing a mask oh my god
sorry i changed my mind i'm voting for
maluma because he's not wearing a mask
oh yeah and he understood the assignment
because honestly everyone looks ugly in
their masks if i'm being honest but oh
here's who's nominated hugh jackman
aaron paul the rock
prince william and maluma honestly like
all oh i accidentally voted for the rock
i'm voting for maluma i have to say this
next one is insane who's the sexiest
housewife's husband harry hamlin todd
tucker who's married to um candy burris
juan dixon married to robin
bill aiden oh that's a good one or
mauricio umansky russia always gets it
i'm voting for billy but the thing is
i'm voting for a fail aiden i don't know
shows we're always remarking on how bill
is just you're a wonderful husband but
when i think like if i had to steal the
husband of any housewife
mostly because he's like one of the few
jewish ones but like it's always
mauricio like successful real estate
agent like supportive husband
knows lots of celebrities
i don't know harry hamlin's really
growing on me this season with all of
his like
farm to table no cooking but i voted for
billy oh this is a good one who's the
sexiest teen soap dreamboat jacob lordy
cole sprouse
darren barnett michael evans belling or
evan mock from gossip girl i honestly
don't know these many but it's obviously
jacob lord agreed
oh i'm sorry no i totally take it back
darren barnett i didn't recognize him at
first
paxton hall yeshida from never have i
ever i know you don't watch the show i
told you you would love it he's so cute
packs in holy [ __ ] i guess my vote okay
next one this is so fun who's the
sexiest peloton instructor
dennis alex ben
cody or matt obviously gotta go cody
because i've never taken the other
people's i don't really know these
people oh no alex
and i'm just going by looks and it's
gonna be like dennis or alex for me
because
he's an amazing instructor fabulous who
is the sexiest accent cristo fernandez
okay i don't know any of these people
claudia you know and said
and i'm skipping this question i refuse
okay you don't want to participate oh
who's the sexiest internet boyfriend now
i feel like we're getting to the dumb
questions okay but this is a good
category timothy chalamet harry styles
winston duke keanu reeves pete davidson
those are the internet's boyfriends st
davidson really more than harry styles
for you
yeah
huh
i'm gonna because also i don't really
feel like harry styles is the internet's
boyfriend honestly it's noah centennial
who's nominated in the next category
it's so true and it's also reggie gene
page yeah
who has the sexiest eyes oh no sorry my
skipped one sexiest smile dev patel
michael b joden jordan omar sai randall
park noah centennial i'm voting for
michael joden
he actually has a great he does a great
smile and he's the hottest one in this
category
sexiest eyes oscar isaac hassan minaj
paul mezcal voted
chris hemsworth or patrick dempsey these
i feel like i'm taking a teen bop quiz
like
what does your crush think of you like
this is so strange i told you it was a
stupid story oh wait sorry here's a good
one sexiest tick tocker noah back
william white santeya frankie jonas oh
brightman rock but i'm going with nobody
noah back we all saw the demilio shot
because he is beautiful on the inside
and out who had the sexiest silver
thirst trap peter
oh it's done i'm sorry peter signing on
it jeff goldblum mark wahlberg chris
maloney mark consuelos john samos it's
chris maloney but but dr um
carlisle carlisle cullen isn't on this
and he posted some sexy silver traps and
he should have won so i'm submitting my
vote for chris maloney and i'm submitted
oh i have to enter my email oh my god i
want my vote to matter yeah okay
done
did i do it yeah okay that was fun
hopefully we'll get to see some results
soon and i would like to see my you know
our votes make a difference
fabulous
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
only if it's the fifth and final story
that's brought to you
by paypal when it's time to pay why pull
out your wallet and open your purse when
you probably already have your phone in
your hand the paypal qr code payments
are now accepted at cvs stores
nationwide so it's super easy to make
touch free payments with your phone plus
you get ten dollars cash back on your
first purchase about 20 or more
so if you're like running out of your
house when i'm walking theo i never
bring my wallet but then i'm always like
you know i could really use a hershey
bar then i don't have my wallet it's
like a whole thing but if i have my
phone i use my paypal qr code and it's
so easy and it's hands-free it's so
sanitary it's like no one wants to be
touching the credit card machine in 2021
like we're beyond that like it's vile so
paypal qr codes are everything of the
sort and now they're accepted at cvs
which like where else does one shop it's
cvs or we're going home and you can also
get that 10 cash back on your first
transaction of 20 or more when you head
to your local cvs and pay using your
paypal or you can use it on the venmo
app that's 10 cashback on your first
purchase of 20 or more with the paypal
or venmo app to see terms and learn more
about how to earn ten dollars cash back
go to paypal.com
toast that's paypal.com toast great okay
our fifth and final story which is the
final story
[Music]
and carly and aaron yeah
sounds so much better with the ponytail
i know but it's hard to control it yeah
oh yeah the triangle goes one of our
literally one of my life's okay so i
have a list of life's regrets not
getting into the cop car okay
what was the other one
they remind me of
i need these lists that we make we need
to start a clipboard like keeping them
we do
stories i always repeat like that's my
favorite country but what are my biggest
regrets i said
whatever
i don't even know where i was going with
the saw it isn't it triangle
is throwing away those little we thought
they didn't matter so when we opened our
triangles from amazon we like threw away
all the other [ __ ] in the box but like
there was actually something really
important in there and it was a
piece of technology in which to hold
your
triangle and we [ __ ] it up and we
[ __ ] up one of my biggest regrets
added to the list okay our fifth and
final story speaking of a piece of
technology some exciting news for kindle
users
amazon unveils three new kindles with
bigger screens and longer battery life
even though the battery life lasts like
six months i don't like a bigger screen
like the kindle's perfect the kindle is
really perfect for my hand size but i do
wonder if there's like a better kindle
out there i mean the one that we're
using is like a really old version yeah
we so we use the paper white e-reader
but they announced three new versions of
the paper white e-reader so that's what
we like it's the paper white paper white
kids edition and paper white signature
edition all models get a new processor a
larger 6.8 inch screen so it's like less
stuff on the sides you know but maybe
it's the same
no i'm so happy with my ten weeks of
battery life
oh my god that's crazy warm light
support and new usb charging
weeks
but it looks huge it looks like an ipad
does it come in multiple sizes
can i get the kids one
i don't know yeah i wish there was an
amazon store but i could try them out
there is but do they sell kindles at the
amazon bookstores there's one in um
union square there's one columbus circle
i signed a couple books there back when
i was a new york times bestselling
author
so yeah i would like to i do believe you
can go in and i don't know if they carry
the kindles but you should just call and
ask
i know for me it's just like if it ain't
broke don't fix it but you know i always
want the best and the brightest i know
me technology but i'm like so this is
the new paper white it looks like ours
but they're saying it's better but it
looks huge too or is that just the
picture yeah that's just the picture
okay
yeah interesting so if you were like on
the fence about getting a kindle i was
just convincing someone to get a kindle
the other day when's pr oh we were we
were talking at christmas bridal shower
yeah and i think i made the sale but she
should wait for the new ones
when
is prime day just passed in july oh [ __ ]
um all right well there's always next
year
all right those were the fast five
stories i feel so you moderately needed
to know them but i had fun while doing
it so that's truly all that matters it
is all that matters and now it's time
for your toasters because there was no
tv on last night that we're going to
recap correct
um all right dear toasters our advice
segment we do it every week and if you
ever want to write in the email is
deartoasters gmail.com we will always
keep you anonymous you can change
people's names certain facts to keep
those people safe first up dear jackie
and claudia oh sorry claudia and jackie
oh i'm not i'm not you're not helping
her
so last year during the pandemic my
husband and i decided that we would move
ourselves and our three kids to a
slightly bigger house with more
amenities how fabulous so we bought a
home in a beautiful country club
community in florida in september of
last year so we just moved in and met a
few of our neighbors at a block party
earlier this year a few weeks ago one of
the neighbors said something to my
husband in passing about a barbecue for
labor day and my husband says it sounds
good we'll be there
that was like beginning of a leann
moriarty book or like a lifetime movie
like it was a barbecue but the only
thing being grilled were the children
you know
then our neighbor messages me on
facebook a few days later and sends me
the invite and the party's actually on
the sunday before labor day when my son
and my husband were flying back in from
going to the georgia game in north
carolina so i knew my husband wasn't
going to want to go but i messaged the
neighbor and said okay we'll try and
make it the day comes and i feel like
laying around in my pool reading and
drinking and not socializing so i
decided we're not gonna go but i didn't
message them
the next day i get a facebook message
from my neighbor kind of scolding me for
not coming to the barbecue that they
invited the entire neighborhood to
basically saying that they made all this
food and did all this planning and that
we didn't show up i apologize then he
kept laying it on saying how his wife
made it nice etc dude it's a barbecue i
didn't miss your wedding like let it go
should i say something or just ignore it
and make nice the next time we see them
also they live like
corner to my house so we see them often
i don't know what that means signed an
annoy toaster i just want to say i am on
your side but rsvp'ing to an event and
then not going like is rude without like
not saying like hey we can't make it
because people do prepare for a certain
amount of people and someone who throws
events quite often like saying you're
coming and they're not coming is rude
yeah and i mean personally i wouldn't
follow up and like let someone know i
was offended and assuming the party was
fun i probably wouldn't have noticed the
people who weren't there but that would
just never follow that's just on seeing
the glass half full no and that's not
like having some integrity but like this
is a small community you're new you
don't want enemies across the street
catty corner so i would maybe like just
send a little something just like
something that's because you don't need
to do that but it would just make her
feel you know
special and maybe smooth things over you
don't want issues no
the more true crime documentaries i
watch the more i realize like you need
your neighbors on your side like that
was my biggest takeaway from the chris
watts documentary like that neighbor
uncovered the whole thing yeah and the
neighbor who was like chris has never
spoken so much in his life yeah like
neighbors are important yeah and a fire
i'm always seeing things on tick tock
like neighbors
like this person's house was on fire
their whole family was asleep inside the
neighbor came and like literally busted
down the door this old woman was like
wake the [ __ ] up you need your neighbors
on your side yeah so make nice and don't
be too proud it's like a neighbor thing
and like you do want to be invited to
the next one and i'm sorry you were in
the wrong you don't want to be the
outcast neighbor no not so early on
right and like maybe you'll make friends
in other neighborhoods like you want to
be on good terms with the neighborhood
like neighbors look out for each other
and i think you should make it right
send a nice candle or something yeah i
like velispa that's my favorite brand of
candle they have really nice ones in
different sizes i like um
what's it called nest thank you she
likes the grapefruit flavor i like
mochara from velaspa i mean if i'm just
like you know i can't pronounce the
brand it's like i think it's volume spa
uh if i'm if i'm not paying for a candle
i love the one that starts with an f
for the seti oh i don't know that one
and people also like diptique and the
the best-selling flavor is base b
b-a-i-e-s yes but but it just really is
1 000 really expensive and then you get
like a tiny candle yeah anyways some
just enjoy candles always such a nice
thing to send by the way little life
hack one time years ago somebody got me
a dip diptique
linen spray so it's the fragrance of the
best-selling candle but it's like a huge
bottle of
you're supposed to spray it on your
linens but when i have company i spray
it all through my house and in the
hallway so like my house smells nice and
it's lasted me for years it's like so
much better than a candle that's really
fragrant that's a good hack for yourself
oh yeah i'm going to share but not
forget i'm just sharing that's nice
thanks i also my favorite nest flavor is
ocean spray and sea salt not mine
grapefruit
next up dear toasters one of my college
best friends is getting married this
winter we're super close throughout
college we had all the same friends
we're on the same sports team were
roommates one year hung out in the
summers etc senior year things got a
little weird when she started dating a
creepy over religious overly religious
older guy who kind of drove a wedge
between us after college i moved to
arizona and she moved back to our
midwest home state we stayed in touch we
we are definitely less close and just
busy with our own lives she invited me
to her bachelorette and i went assuming
i wasn't in the bridal party since she
hadn't said anything thinking maybe it
was just going to be like a small party
or she was gonna have her sister stand
up with her etc
i only found out mid-bachelorette
weekend that she's having seven girls
including two girls from college who i
barely remember her even speaking to my
feelings are hurt and i'm a bit confused
do i say something or ask why i wasn't
included do i even go to the wedding
other people close to the situation have
commented on how weird it is that they
think i'm not in it as well to add
insult to injury she didn't give me a
plus one because i'm not engaged or
married even though i've been dating my
boyfriend of two years for two years and
i'd be traveling to the wedding love the
show you guys kill me please advise
this is tough because like i don't know
because you're not gonna like what we
have to say i know cause like it's her
wedding and it's just like not about you
and like if i thought i was close to
someone and they didn't make me a
bridesmaid when like i really thought i
would have been
then that's the message received like
okay we're not as close as i thought i
am like i'll just come to your wedding
as a guest so like you said yourself
that you guys like aren't that close
like you drifted away starting senior
year now you don't even live near each
other and you said like you went on the
bachelorette party assuming you're not a
bridesmaid the only thing that's now
bothering you is that there are other
people
who
she wasn't close with in college who are
in the bachelorette party like you don't
know that they might be keeping in touch
yeah
i would just say message received yeah
and when you're not in the bridal party
and like most people institute a no ring
no bring policy like
no i didn't know bring i didn't yeah you
have to and it's hard it's really hard
but you have to like be consistent about
it you can't say this person oh they're
two years this person is a year and a
half right but they seem closer and
they're having trouble like and at this
point you're not in the bridal party
you're just a guest like you're just
following guest rules like
it's probably sucks and but maybe you're
also just a guest you're not in the
writing party you don't have to go and
you apparently have to travel like she
said she sent you a message you've
received it you don't have to go know
where you stand you don't have to go
that's the silver lining for you but
is this like if you don't go then like
you're officially taking your friendship
like down like two notches so or do you
want to do that
but yeah i i don't think the whole
boyfriend thing is a big deal even
though it sucks a lot of especially in
covid like we have so many like capacity
you know time limits yeah
no ring no brain is a rule that is tough
but i did have it at my wedding and i
stand by it like a hundred percent there
for a reason yeah
i'm sorry you just need some sort of
standard to apply to everybody's
relationship it's just like a free food
in some instances it definitely is harsh
you know some people have been together
for so long and yeah whatever but you
know no that's also the crazy thing like
in movies when it's like i have a
wedding would you be my plus one it's
like
how free willy is the bride like i
always like think that like i went as a
date with someone to a wedding what yeah
no like all right i met my what the day
for wedding like on tinder like i'm it's
like who was this a 600 person wedding
no i totally agree i always think that's
so weird so weird and especially if
you're a bridesmaid sometimes all the
bridal party gets plus ones even if
they're not in a relationship but then
it's like if you're a bridesmaid
you're busy the whole time you can't
deal with entertain a third day tinder
date yeah totally
i agree that's a plot hole
totally all right next one is the final
one and it's a little long hi claude and
jack
first of all just wants to disrespect me
today no they said congrats on the bad
bad news jackie i'm so excited for you
in the family sending your best wishes
for an easy pregnancy thank you so
dearly okay i've been married for almost
two years to my pgm husband that i've
been with for 12 years since high school
before we got married we talked about
changing my name to his and initially i
wanted to hyphenate my name for some
background i have two sisters and we're
all really close to my dad and we're a
close-knit family in general so needless
to say i'm proud of my last name and it
means a lot to me after talking to my
then fiance i could tell that he really
wanted me to fully take on his last name
and drop mine i'm a bit of a people
pleaser so i did just that and i moved
my last name and added it to my middle
name
ever since i did that i've always felt
weird about my new last name when i see
packages or go to the doctor and have to
say my new last name it just feels like
a part of me is missing it also doesn't
help that my dad and my family gave me a
hard time for completely dropping my
last name i've recently recently looked
into what i could do to change my name
yet again so i can add back my last name
and hyphenate it and basically i'd have
to file a petition with the court get it
approved and then update all my [ __ ]
like a driver's license social security
passport i talked to my husband about it
and to be honest and i took my husband
about it to be honest about how how i
was feeling and he obviously was not
thrilled he said he ultimately wants me
to do whatever is going to make me feel
like me but that he's also bummed
because he thought i had taken his name
and was proud of it my question is what
the hell should i do if i could go back
in time i'd 100 hyphenate my name if
there's any way i can change it now
should i
should my thoughts should my husband's
thoughts about it upset me
would love to know your thoughts a
confused toaster
i'm confused no i'm not confused i i
don't know what to tell you honestly
because it's clearly very personal
decision and like i
did not change my name and i feel
weirdly about it because in so many ways
like i'm very traditional but with the
whole same thing i'm just like not into
it at all like so much paperwork and i
am who i am and like we're all girls
like we have
on our dad's side like we have boy
cousins and we have a half brother but i
don't know i just feel like it's
my responsibility to carry on the
austrian name like i'm in no rush i
think where it becomes and i think where
most people get comfortable with their
married name is when they have kids
because then you're like we are the
kleinbergs or whatever you know yes no i
agree
i haven't made moves on changing my name
but my plan was always you know move my
last name to my middle name
take my husband's last name and i and i
will do that eventually i'm just lazy um
but i understand how you might be
feeling i don't know that like doing a
hyphen
like why can't you just why do you have
to do it legally why can't you just have
everyone call you
your middle and last name like yeah
that's true because there's two things
going on here legally changing your name
and socially changing your name are two
very different things like it's your
facebook name and your instagram name
and you know like the name you've signed
on forms like
that's pretty good yeah
like for a while i was going around like
claudia ashrae software but like
i don't know i i i'm struggling with the
same thing i don't feel like i can give
advice here because like i'm struggling
with the same thing too but also because
like art
like
jackie oh that's like my it's a branding
show too like when when i've literally
worked for last 10 years like get people
to know my name i'm not about to just
change it like but i actually have so
much respect for influencers who change
it like pretty immediately well
sometimes and then and then you really
do
everyone comes around sometimes it is
best for your brand like lauren lane
lauren bushnell was fabulous too but
lauren lane is like meant to be an
influencer but like i was following um
arielle what was nasmani
when she got married and she went
charnes immediately and it took i was
like this is so weird and now i couldn't
even remember almost her last name no
like rache parcell like she her sister
her scala her sisters aren't parcel oh
my god that's so true i always think of
them as the parcel family but they're
not no they're not so it's actually like
i feel like either like my friend anna
changed her name right after like
immediately facebook legally and now to
me she's on amslam like i
don't think anything of it yeah but i
feel like if you teeter like i don't
know what should i do like then it makes
it harder yeah so like just gotta rip
the band-aid off or not if you don't
want to do it yeah but i don't feel like
we have to do it anymore like it's the
21st century like i'm not i don't have
to do anything but like you know clearly
your husband feels some type of way
about it and
i don't know just
i wouldn't go through the process of
changing it again because that's just a
lot of work i know i just feel like
legally like it doesn't matter what your
name is like
his name is montero like nobody knows
that if they like do the hyphen then i
guess the kids will have that name the
hyphen name got it got it got it got it
but the hyphen doesn't make me feel any
better about nothing and also like this
is what i'm really struggling with like
kids who had hyphen and names in school
like we're weird i'm sorry like why do
you have three names like it is weird
i'm sorry and i know that's me and now
as an adult i understand exactly why the
parents did what they did but that
doesn't mean that their life as children
is going to be easy it's an identity
crisis you know i totally get it now but
like as a kid i'm like haha you have
three names like that was just what it
was like hyphenated kids were weird i'm
like sorry i don't make the rules still
doesn't make your name
go more than another 20 years like you
still won't pass down your name it's
just okay we have 20 30 years till it
expires yeah until that kid gets married
yeah
it's not like the wife is taking the
hyphen right right so the next grandkids
take the hyphen i feel like the name of
it like the naming industry it's a
problem i think a lot of modern women
are facing i think about it all the time
yeah because like i want to be the
soccer family like when we have kids but
like i'm claudia ashrae and i'm sorry
that's not changing i know i'm glad i
feel you and
does that make me like a bad wife like
because i love being claudia ashrae like
she's the best her google search results
may not be great but she's a really good
person she has a good heart she does and
like i don't know i just want to be her
i'm sorry i don't think claudius offer
has those things
i don't know it's not just don't know
her i know i don't want to say anything
negative about claudia's software i'm
sure she's a great person too i just
personally feel so attached to claudia
ashrae like i don't think i'll honestly
if i'm being honest like ever change it
okay
so i can't give advice here i'm just
commiserating with you girlfriend i feel
you i'm like
i really can't give it back i'm in no
position to give advice either because
i'm still in like this limbo right no
and it's like you're i think you're in a
limbo if you don't change your name
immediately after you get married you're
in this limbo till you have kids but
like people who change their instagrams
like the day after they get married like
i'm like that's it's smart i'm sorry
like
building start it's smart like you
already start to associate the name even
when i'm watching a tv show and like
someone gets married and you know they
like by the way you should watch a place
to call home when you finish downton it
will i started it i didn't think it was
that great but now it's so [ __ ] good
okay
anyways she was like sarah nordman sarah
bly and i was just you know it sticks it
doesn't take that long before it sticks
yeah
okay
um well our episode is not over but that
was your toasters again if you ever want
to write in it's dear toasters gmail.com
and
if you've written us in recently and
we've read it on air and you have an
update for us like let us know how
things went did you follow our advice
did you not follow our advice send us
another email we would absolutely love
to hear from you
and the show's not over the rest of the
show is coming and it's brought to you
by manscaped autumn is in the air the
pumpkins are in the patch and our
friends at manscaped are here to try and
make sure your man doesn't carve his
pants pumpkins when he's grooming if you
know what i'm saying make sure he's
keeping things fresh this fall with the
leaders in male grooming and their brand
new 4th generation performance package
do we really want to cuddle up with a
dude who isn't trimmed get him to take
the leap into fall with manscaped
so
either i'll change my name if you escape
your man their new manscape performance
package 4.0 comes with a lawnmower
trimmer a weed whacker ear and nose hair
trimmer a crop preserver ball deodorant
crop reviver toner and two free gifts
boxer briefs and the travel bag which is
literally the best part um it's a great
gift for the man in your life it's a
gift for you and for them because we're
all winning when we're manscaping
the new performance package 4.0 includes
the lawnmower so if you're looking to
cozy up with your man this fall this
trimmer is essential um and it comes
with just the best technology to prevent
knicks snags tugs in those delicate
areas if you know what i'm saying they
also throw in those two free gifts so
that's the boxers and the shed travel
bag it's everything of the sort perfect
gift holidays are coming up and we're
all winning when we're manscaping so get
20 off and free shipping with the code
toast at manscaped.com that's 20 off
plus free shipping with the code toast
at manscape.com make sure his balls are
fresh this fall with manscaped um okay
so
if you're listening as a podcast just
keep listening we sat down i sat down
with carly and aaron um and they were
just like the girliest of girls and i
feel like it was a really good episode
and it was really cool to hear about how
they started
their careers living in l.a carly's from
nebraska and i was just like tell me
more like so jealous um and i think she
thought i was kidding but she doesn't
know like how much we crave the life of
farm chairman she doesn't know um so it
was really good and we talked about like
vlog squad so i think you guys will
enjoy it if you're listening on the
podcast just keep listening and if
you're on youtube it's another video and
it'll
be up
right now so just check it out thank you
guys so much for listening to the
morning toast monday morning show we
deliver the best of stories that you
need to every monday through friday on
youtube watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found so that's spotify itunes stitch or
public radio i heart video cast blocks
all the places where we listen to the
podcast by not supporting until 75 star
view about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are and if you have still made
it to the end of the episode
congratulations you are part of the
society season 2 where only real true
toasters make it to this part of the
episode and to let us know that you have
made it go head over to our instagram
and leave a comment on our most recent
picture of us looking so cute and make
it the emoji of a light bulb no i feel
like i've done that already um i always
try and like look at things
and be like light bulb like i'm
television like blanket like what you
know yeah that's interesting no uh do
the emoji of
the newspaper because we've done that we
didn't have them so the panda okay sure
the panda because he's so cute enjoy the
uh interview with carly and erin and
we'll see you guys tomorrow bye
you